take me to see Araucana can't gotta get
to the chopper now what a change teach
you for call me an ugly [ __ ] if
you bleed I can kill you it's blood was
on the leaves it bleeds we can kill it
what no roses just gods
[Music]
any chance we settle this peaceably no
hasta LaVista baby hasta la vista baby
why are you upset because cage turned on
your learning computer chill out
Jax chill out dickwad five bucks says
you're here to kill me of course I'm a
terminator
Jesus you're gonna kill that guy of
course I'm a terminator
you just can't go around killing people
why not you just can't trust me you just
can't go around killing people
why because you just can't okay trust me
on this
I have detailed files on human anatomy
to make you a more efficient killer
correct
I have detailed files on human anatomy
I bet makes you a more efficient killer
right correct your mouths help disguise
I can't recall those files totally this
I have to see
[Music]
how long you've been here
two weeks two weeks too long you asked
me how long you plan to stay on Mars two
weeks you will take me to Sarah Connor
think of me as your Johnny cab you lie
where can I take you tonight
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not familiar with that
address
Johnny Cage gave you the code name and
just what is lewd mind come up with
Doris and your code name will be Natasha
no Doris
have you killed anyone yeah but they
were all bad have you ever killed anyone
yeah but they were all bad your
observation is incorrect you sure that
next pretty thick it is not a tumor I
have a headache
it might be a tumor it's not a tumor
it's not a tumor at all
is it true sub-zero's now plain zero my
mission objective is complete damn here
is Sub Zero now plane zero are you sure
about that yes
show me your speed all right then it's
turbo time
see Araucana so your blade also targeted
for termination six decide to protect
you you've been targeted for termination
I need guns rifles semi-auto what kind
Warren so which will it be
all closed early today just a dollar he
wouldn't hurt me would you sweetheart
wrong
you will serve me cyborg what is your
mission to crush my enemies and see them
driven before crush the enemies see them
driven before you and they hear a
lamentation of the women to be or not to
be leave or be terminated not to be to
be or not to be not to be
you